uh make researching your thing today
yeah
already sort of stated that but yeah we
need to push the button soon
so many good news now
focus on the price i'm here to win today
oh i shouldn't take back that's not it
quincy too can you afford that
i have no idea to be honest
i learned
recently that you should you should oh
e3 wins
oh
do i miss that
i feel like this guy was
just prepared for everything 95 hanks as
well this has been a pathetic game
this guy
i just ran into
a prepared line
or not specifically prepared for me just
the line that he knows and then
doll went very very south
from there i can't even take can i
okay we'll go
g4 doesn't matter though
okay now he's messing it up just a tad
so he's got this one
probably shouldn't be
playing on but
not
i have to try something dirty here
clearly
okay now
my position is
improving now the position is drawn
wow
nice save
okay i don't know if it was worth that i
was about to say this is when you
resigned the magnus but you fought yeah